انضم إليّ ميشا كاتسيران ، إنه
نداء متدرب في أوكرانيا الآن وميشا
والدك في روسيا وبعد أيام من القصف
وأيام من هذا الغزو كنت
تتساءل لماذا لم يتصل
بك في أوكرانيا ، لذا حصلت عليه أخيرًا
على الهاتف ، ما الذي قاله
كان مثل المحادثة الشائعة ،
كيف حالك ، أي كلمة عن
الحرب وسألته هل تعرف ما الذي
يحدث وقال نعم ، لقد سمعت
شيئًا وبدأت أخبره أه كيف  هي أشيائي
وأشياء من عائلتي ، فقلت
له أننا استيقظنا من القصف
وأنني أخذت ابني الصغير الذي
يبلغ من العمر ثمانية أشهر وحاولنا أن
نحب أم
الهروب واه لإنقاذ الأسرة وأه هي
بدأت في  تجادل
بأنها قالت لا ، ليس كل شيء ليس على
هذا
النحو وأخبرتني أن روسيا بدأت
كعملية سلمية وأنهم يحاولون
إنقاذنا من نظام النازيين
الذي احتل بلدنا
وأه كان الشيء المثير للاهتمام هو أه
الجنود الروس  يعطون اه  بالنسبة لسكانهم
المحليين ، الطعام والملابس الدودية ،
فهذا هو الشيء الذي شاهده على التلفزيون
وقالوا إنه لا أب الآن أنا هنا ، أرى
ما يحدث لأصدقائي أيضًا ، انظر أيضًا إلى
ما يحدث
وأه لا يستطيع أن يؤمن بهذا
الأمر ، لذلك
أنا  أمضيت ربما خمس دقائق في محاولة
التحدث إليه ، ثم أقول وداعًا
آسف
لذلك كانت هذه أول محادثة بينهما تقول
أبي إنهم
يقصفوننا ويقول لا لا ، هذا ليس ما
يحدث ، لا
كل شيء ، نعم ، لذا فهو لا يستطيع
تصديق  في هذا الواقع ، فهم موجودون في
واقع آخر تم إنشاؤه
منذ 20 عامًا وأنت تعرف متى يكون مثل
أه كل يوم على التلفزيون في الصحف
مثل الراديو الفيدرالي ولا توجد
وسائط مجانية في روسيا يحبونها أم حصلت على
المعلومات التي تفيد بأن  شجرة خلفهم
حمراء
ثم اتصلت به وقلت لا
أب الشجرة خضراء ، لا يمكنه تصديق
أنه يريد أن يصدقني ، لكنه لا يستطيع
أن يصل إليه على الإطلاق ، هل
تعتقد أنه بعد مناقشتك كان لديه
إحساس بأنك  تعرض للقصف
وغزوه ، كان ذلك مثل
آه بطريقة ما ، لذا بعد أن انتهيت من هذه
المناقشة ، قمت بعمل منشور في Instagram
أن والدي لا يصدقني وأه
كان هناك أكثر من 135000
مشاركة في هذا المنشور ، لذلك أدركت أن
المشكلة كبيرة  منتشر مثل
الآلاف وشيء من التعليقات
وكتب كل الناس أن لدي
نفس الشيء أمي لا تصدقني
أختي لا تصدقني عمي
لا يصدقني
وأدركت أن هذا مثل ضخم
مشكلة ضخمة ضخمة واه اجتمعنا مع
زملائي وانشأنا موقعهم الالكتروني
الذي يسمى اب صدق في هذا
الموقع
نود ان
نحاول اه ان نقدم للناس الاتصال
بأقاربهم واخبارهم
بالحقيقة ونحب كتابة
كل الاساسيات  أسئلة الدعاية الروسية
وإجابات هذه الأسئلة
لأن أسهل شيء هو أن
تقول حسنًا ليس لدي أب لأن
هذا مرهق جدًا عندما تكون مغلقًا
لأن الناس لا يصدقون أه  لقد
بدأت في
الصراخ ، وبدأت في الغضب الشديد ، وفي هذا الشيء الذي يعجبني ،
أدركت
أنني بحاجة إلى الهدوء ،
أحتاج إلى أن أكون ذكيًا وأحتاج إلى الاتصال
به مرارًا وتكرارًا
ومساعدته لأنه مثل تخيل بشكل صحيح  الآن ،
أغلقت روسيا
الانستغرام ، لقد أغلقوا فيسبوك ، لقد
أغلقوا علامة التجزئة ، لذلك هناك
الطريقة الوحيدة للحصول على معلومات مثل من
القنوات الفيدرالية
وهذا هو السبب في أن
الأقارب الآن هم الوسيلة الوحيدة
التي يمكن أن تعجبهم بإخبارهم
جانبًا آخر من المعلومات  أه
وهناك أكثر من 11 مليون من
الأقارب في روسيا الآن ، لذا
تخيل فقط أه إذا أحب الناس
قول الحقيقة لهم وسيقولون الحقيقة
ليحبوا اثنين من أصدقائهم سيكون
33 مليون شخص سيعرفون
الحقيقة أن
هذه هي القوة الهائلة